this is cctv from a corridor on the
intensive care floor
of a hospital in southern baghdad it's
just before 10 30 on saturday night
watch the right of the screen and the
flash as an oxygen tank explodes
[Applause]
within a few seconds the flames are
already starting to spread
firefighters spent hours trying to get
the fire under control
at least 200 people were rescued and
transferred to other hospitals
in the iraqi capital
i took her on my shoulders and i ran
down people were jumping from over there
doctors fell on the cars everyone was
jumping
we have been looking for them for over
an hour there is no trace
we went to the morgue to every hospital
we can't find any of them
many of the victims were covered
patients they were on oxygen to fight
the virus
by sunday hundreds were still
unaccounted for and their relatives were
searching the remains for them
how could i leave my father i stayed
with him i tried to drag him out but i
couldn't because he'd lost consciousness
when the smoke became more intense and
the oxygen tanks exploded
i lost consciousness i don't know what
happened
iraq's health system has been ruined by
decades of war
sanctions and neglect the country's
prime minister has given the health
authorities 24 hours
to deliver results of an investigation
but already
most iraqis are pointing the finger at
the system
and those in power alastair bunker sky
news